Interview
My beloved sister Mari I have
just arrived in the city where Marie lives.The
work of the Knights of Macau is hard, but for Marie it's not
hard.I can buy presents with my salary.
[Music]
I was a prisoner who wanted  This is how I'm living my life
decently I can shoot with the help of an angel It's because of Marie, who I thought was pitiful, and it
's all thanks to Marie
I can't wait to talk to you
, Mr. Family head
I've got it ready
Hurry up and get a guidebook Yes For example,
first of all, here's a bar that's called a plush stuffed toy lady o Miss
I'm sure she'll be happy with an angelic smile
I'm sure you'll spend your days living with your big brother in a mansion like this, and you'll
definitely work hard at playing house
.  Let's go to the telegraph
[music]
Give me everything in the store every time id